so
john what how was the media at that time
covenant covering this i mean obviously
we don't have
the the fox cnn cbs abc any we don't
have the kind of media that we have
today
who's writing about it opposing
president wilson while he's saying
everything's fine don't worry about it
who's opposing and telling stories about
what's really going on
pretty much nobody in 1918 uh
you know the the newspapers in the
country
uh number one they were patriotic and
wanted to support the war effort
number two they had that law that i told
you about a minute ago that if you
criticized the government you could go
to jail and the congressman was
sentenced to prisoners
uh so in most cases in most cities
the uh newspapers simply
went along with the program and
printed lies i'll give you a couple of
examples
uh in philadelphia which was one of the
hardest hit cities in the united states
hundreds are dying every day in
philadelphia probably about 15 000
totals
when they finally and they're using
steam shovels to dig mass graves
you literally have priests in
philadelphia driving horse-drawn carts
down the street
calling upon people to bring out their
dead
so when they finally in philadelphia
closed saloons closed theaters closed
schools and so forth and so on
one of the newspapers actually said a
direct quote
this is not a public health measure you
have no cause for a panic or alarm
unquote and yet
people you know their neighbors are
dropping dead
you know they're mass graves being dug
they're
using reusing coffins
because they didn't have any coffins and
the newspaper
is saying this is not a public health
measure
so i mean how stupid did they think
their readers were
the readers knew what was going on um
another example in in little rock you
know i
i quoted uh a doctor in in uh
an army camp uh a couple miles out
actually i guess seven or eight miles
outside of little rock
uh talking about thousands in the in the
base hospital you know card is
overflowing
with with beds beds outside the hospital
uh and he writes there's nothing here
but death and destruction
just a few miles away in little rock
arkansas
the arkansas gazette princess big
headlines spanish influenza
same old chills and grip and
and you know it's just total dismissive
just like
it was ordinary influenza uh you know
there are a couple of exceptions
uh there's a small city in wisconsin
where the uh
newspaper started to print the truth and
the army started to institute
prosecution against them uh
under that law i mentioned a little
while ago
uh although the prosecution was dropped
as the pandemic proceeded uh
san francisco is is a
uh was pretty exceptional and san
francisco
uh which got hit pretty late actually
the uh in you know most cities
say they're saying things like this is
ordinary influence by another name
san francisco the mayor the business
leaders
trade union leaders and the medical
community all got together
signed a joint statement huge typeface
in the newspapers saying where mass can
save your life
uh what was the matter within 18. this
is in 1918
where a mass can save a life say you
save your life
so that is a very different message than
saying this is ordinary influenza
by another name which was the most
common treatment of it in the press
or a third example in phoenix
they wrote a little bit about it when
the disease erupted in boston which was
the first place in the united states to
get hit by the
disease game and waves and the second
wave was
the deadly wave so
when it's in boston they write a little
bit about it in phoenix
when it's in new orleans they write less
about it in phoenix
when it's actually in phoenix it
disappears from the newspapers
not a word initially because
again they didn't want any bad news out
there that might hurt the war effort
eventually when it was impossible to
ignore
uh the phoenix paper did start writing
about it but
again initially to
keep morale up and so forth and so on uh
they ignored it you know in other
newspapers they simply they
didn't even print names of the people
who died
and you know all of this had
a impact on the public and it wasn't
what they wanted
instead of keeping morale up it hurt
morale more than
the truth would have uh because people
knew again their neighbors are dying
in some cases the bodies are lying in
the house for days because there's no
one to get take it out
and they ca and people knew this was
happening
all around them they knew that they were
being lied to by the
by the media and by the public officials
and all that did was alienate them and
and
caused them to feel that they had no one
they could rely on
except for themselves uh and
you know it's sort of split society
apart john for you
did you ever sit down and have a
conversation about this with your
grandparents
i'm assuming your parents are probably
born in the 20s
or or late teens actually my mother just
died at 102 and she was born in 1918.
oh and you got to be kidding me wow
but when i first started working on the
book
you know my grandparents were dead uh
but i had
anon who was considerably older than my
mother
uh and when i told her that i was
working on the book
i mean she sort of like grabbed her to
her chest and said
oh my god then you know that's the only
time she ever saw her father
to cry that was because a couple
directly across the street who had a
couple of kids
you know both of them died uh leaving
several orphans which was not uncommon
because as i said earlier the
18 to 45 is like the peak a
age at which people were dying so there
were a lot of orphans created
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you